hey guys I'm out of the country at the
moment but we didn't want to leave you
hanging with no clips so here's just
some general Insanity of the day I think
according to the climate scientists
around the world and certainly The
Cutting Edge scientists that we need to
rely on here in the U.S we've got to get
carbon neutral by 2050 and I'm very
comfortable with that Target and I think
that's the appropriate about 2050 which
is only 27 years that is not a long time
away and and how much will that cost
so the cost that I focus on even more is
all the costs that are going to happen
if we don't cost to get us carbon Newton
it's going to cost trillions of dollars
and it'll cost tens of trillions of
dollars if we don't get our act how many
trillions I don't have the estimate or
the numbers in front of me I've seen a
variety of different estimates but it's
a large amount fundamentally
Transforming Our energy economy tell me
the estimate deal tell me the estimates
that you've seen I don't have those
numbers right on hand so so you're
advocating that we become Karma neutral
but you don't know how much it's going
to cost so there's an awful lot of
estimates out there it depends your
technology
you're the expert I know that I know how
much it's going to cost I know with the
certainty of all the experts I've spoken
about it's cheaper to get our act
together than it is to not get our act
together on climate change then tell me
the cost
that we if we don't do it I think it's
orders of magnitude different
you don't have a cost you want us to get
there but you can't tell the American
taxpayer how much it's going to cost
is that your testimony it's going to
save us money and there's a lot of jobs
well how do we know you don't know how
much it's going to cost
I'd be happy to pull up the latest
numbers that I've seen how about 50
trillion dollars is that right it's
going to cost trillions of dollars
there's no doubt about it okay if we
spend trillions of dollars
and we achieve
some of your colleagues estimate 50
trade and it disappoints me that you're
not willing to give the estimates
I I don't I hope you're not telling me
you have no idea how much it's going to
cost that creates a whole new host of
problems
but but uh if it costs 50 trillion
dollars if some of your colleagues have
testified to become carbon neutral by
2050.
and I'm all for carbon neutrality by the
way
how much is that going to lower World
temperatures
or how much is that going to reduce the
increase in World temperatures so every
country around the world needs to get
its act together our emissions are about
13 percent of global yeah but if you
could answer my question if we spend 50
trillion dollars
to become carbon neutral in the United
States of America by 2050.
you're the deputy secretary of energy
give me your estimate of how much that
is going to reduce World temperatures so
so first of all it's a net cost
um it's what uh benefits we're having
from getting our act together and
reducing all of those climate benefits
we're seeing let me ask again maybe I'm
being right now maybe I'm not being
clear if we spent 50 trillion dollars to
become carbon neutral by 2050 in the
United States of America how how much is
that going to reduce World temperatures
this is a global problem so we need to
reduce our emissions and we need to do
everything we can how much if we do our
part is it going to reduce well we're 13
of global you don't know do you
you don't know do you can do the math we
need to you don't know do you Mr
secretary
so we're 13 if you know why won't you
tell me if we went to zero that would be
13 you don't know do you you just want
us to spend 50 trillion dollars
and you don't have the slightest idea
whether it's going to reduce World
temperatures now I'm all for carbon
neutrality but you're the deputy
secretary of the Department of energy
and you're advocating we spend trillions
of dollars to seek carbon neutrality and
you can't and this isn't your money and
my money it's taxpayer money and you
can't tell me how much it's going to
lower World temperatures or you won't
tell me you know but you won't in my
heart of hearts there is no way the
world gets its act together on climate
change unless the US leads tell me how
much it's going to reduce you can't tell
me either that or you won't